I was born in Chengdu
She also graduated from Chengdu University.
Then I started working after graduation and founded Tap4Fun in 2008.
Tap4Fun is a Chinese company in Chengdu, specializing in developing games for mobile devices.
Our focus is on developing games for mobile devices only.
The development of mobile games has become essential
It is also the philosophy of establishing the company to maintain its business continuity and profits.
The beginning of the company was very funny
Because there was no small office available at the time.
But this has led us to cooperate with each other inside and outside the office
The dedication of the team members was also very strong.
The company is headquartered in China but we do not design games for China.
This is something that usually surprises people.
Around 2013, we began to notice that Google Play was experiencing really rapid growth
And that the Android app market is on the way to expanding enormously.
So it was impossible to ignore that.
So we've studied the idea of ​​publishing one of our games on Google Play and observing its performance
Google Play revenue is 55% of our total gaming revenue
While Google Play players account for 65% of all our game users.
This is because users are instantly updating games within one hour
From updating or uploading an app.
Google has a good relationship with developers
Their support staff is very much in touch with us
To ask if we need help.
Then they share with us the stage of developing games and give us suggestions.
In addition to this, they are very interested in each game as well as offering great solutions.
Our trial use in Google Play allows us to publish new releases
By specifically targeting a particular segment of players
So we not only create the release, we also care about the experience of our users
By avoiding issuing a release to the public only after making sure that it is free of any problems.
Google is striving for the success of all developers globally
So they do much to encourage everyone to achieve this kind of success.
Another factor is the impact that Google is making around the world.
So for us, Google Play is the starting point for success.
When we publish our game on Google Play, players from around the world are more likely to reach it
Operating and enjoying it and this is really important to us.
It is assumed that there is an important customer support system
And that players who pay for the game will be supported by distinguished members
We also care about solving the problems players face through Google's opinion system.
In this way, the ratings for our players increased from 3.6 to 4.2
Meanwhile, the number of messages with comments and those sent to customer service is decreasing
By players at a rate ranging from 15% to 20% in the following days.
As far as I am concerned, I believe that the Statute must be appropriate
From openness, availability and excellence to support any company or team
He is thinking of producing high-quality games for the world market.
Google Play represents this type of platform.